we've all seen the adverts pretty much
everyone on the internet is telling you
to leave your job and go work for
yourself if you're not already side
hustling your way to a million you
should flip your soyboy boss off as you
hand in your resignation to carve out
your own destiny but there are some huge
dark sides to running your own business
that the hustle and grind world will
never tell you about so allow me to piss
on this parade here are 10 reasons why
working for yourself
absolutely sucks number one you are only
ever accountable to yourself not having
to answer to a boss sounds fantastic no
more pointless tuesday morning meetings
and no one whinging if you return late
from lunch
but that accountability provided
structure now
not only are you the guy doing the work
you're the guy telling the guy to do the
work so
no one is going to tell you off if that
email doesn't get sent on time or that
presentation is a little bit over budget
the only person who pays that price is
you
and your business
and your accounts and your long-term
financial prospects after 15 years of
running businesses i can tell you that
being both the organ grinder and the
monkey is exhausting and flip-flopping
from neuroticism to apathy
isn't a good situation number two never
knowing when you're finished many people
start their own business to take control
of their time but being in charge of
your own workload means that there's
always something else to complete
instead of having a prescribed list of
tasks to move through before 5 pm
now you have a never-ending conveyor
belt of things to do over time your life
can become invaded by a permanent sense
that there's unfinished work
this ambient to-do list anxiety may well
help you to stay competitive but that
doesn't mean it will actually increase
your quality of life over time your
typical finish goes from five to six to
seven pm
and it's very hard to turn around once
you've started down that road
this can turn into a vicious cycle of
mounting workloads and increasing guilt
leading to more work and more guilt and
so on and so on the price that you pay
in missed events time with friends and
family and just opportunities to
experience life is real yes
you are your own boss at work now but
your work has become the real boss of
your life number three attaching your
sense of self-worth to the success of
the business i spent most of my 20s
feeling great when the businesses were
doing well and terrible when they were
doing badly even though most of their
performance was out of my control this
is a recipe for disaster you can do
all the things correctly you can send
the emails on time and come up with
awesome marketing campaigns and create
the right product
and the market responds in the way the
market responds especially if you're a
young entrepreneur this is a real risk
you're basically outsourcing your sense
of happiness
and well-being and confidence to a third
party that you have a negligible control
over previously there was a buffer right
between your work and its outcomes but
now it feels like a direct relationship
if you are what you do
then your value is how well you do it
you care about your business so
obviously you want to do something that
makes you feel proud and fulfilled but
very quickly this can turn from
emotional investment into identity
attachment number four permanently
having to create your own motivation in
a normal job you externalize motivation
to your colleagues and your boss and the
company rules but this support system is
no longer there even if you're starting
a business with colleagues and employees
the book stops with you now if you don't
do it it won't get done and no one but
yourself can motivate you this can
become
absolutely exhausting now not only do
you need the motivation to do the work
you need the motivation to tell yourself
to do the work
this strains your willpower reserves for
other things not only in your business
but outside of it too your motivation to
train hard or stick to a diet or build a
new habit will suffer because of how
much effort you need to expend just to
keep your business going number five
holidays and downtime barely exist i
spent
204 saturdays in a row setting up the
same club night and never took a holiday
which lasted longer than four days until
i was 26 because i was terrified of
leaving my business for too long i only
went on reality tv because they promised
me that they could get me back to our
event ready for the doors to open on a
saturday night
your competitive advantage comes from
noticing things that your competitors
don't and being more detailed and
creative and consistent this is the
superpower of a small agile lean startup
but it's really hard to switch off
even if you do manage to shoehorn some
time away in that doesn't mean that your
mind will be on vacation as well you
will be on holiday somewhere warm and
sunny and lovely and relaxing thinking
about a project that you need to finish
when you get back to your laptop also
genuine creativity comes from stepping
away from the tasks that you need to do
the reason that you were probably good
in the first place is that you were able
to see things that the rest of the
market wasn't if you're not careful you
can spend so much time ruminating about
work that you never get the distance
needed to actually be creative number
six never being certain if what you're
working on next is the right thing when
you're both the person who makes the
rules and follows the rules you can get
caught up spending a lot of time
questioning instead of executing there
are no standard operating procedures for
you to follow usually if you had a
question about what to do next you just
ask your boss this outsources the
decision-making and the culpability for
getting it wrong
to them now you don't have that free
pass even after a while when you've
created a typical working routine the
fact that you made the routine will
always leave you with this distracting
sense that
maybe you should be doing something else
number seven no assurances about income
another reason people start their own
business
is because they want to be in control of
making their own money no longer are
your efforts and your outcomes detached
from each other now you take on the risk
and receive the reward but there are
no assurances here the market does not
give a single [ __ ] about you it doesn't
care how hard you've worked you can do
absolutely everything right and watch
your revenue get chopped in half next
month some months you'll double your
income
and some months you'll make nothing you
need to ask yourself whether you can
handle this
really think about it in a normal job
you'll receive your paycheck no matter
how the company is performing
some people are built for this
monetary orderliness they're like stable
linear progression that they can predict
and it makes them feel safe if you
strike out on your own you become your
own pension backup plan holiday
allowance sick leave and pay rise
all rolled into one watching your
financial security get ragged around at
the mercy of market forces
isn't fun number eight it becomes much
harder to get a mortgage buying a house
or building a property portfolio is on
many people's lists of financial goals
if you're in a typical employment and
have about 25 to put down you can
usually find a bank to lend you around
five times your annual salary to buy a
house if you're self-employed however
the bank will scrutinize your accounts
much more closely in the uk you'll need
to provide three years of sa 302s which
are the self-assessments of annual
income plus they may even dig deeper
into the sources of that to look at
wages dividends and any other forms of
income that you've received i don't know
how it works in america
but i can't imagine it's any prettier
this means you essentially cannot get a
mortgage if you've been self-employed
for less than three years that might not
sound like long but if you're holding up
your ability to enter the market or move
into a dream home it will feel like an
eternity number nine
paperwork
even if you have a huge team and a [ __ ]
hot assistant you will have to deal with
more paperwork realistically you'll
probably have to do most if not all of
it yourself articles of incorporation
bank accounts trademarks leases business
rates and then constant ongoing checks
of these is beyond tedious yes
it's cool to have a bank account with
your company name on it but no one talks
about the headaches of submitting your
annual expenses every year or dealing
with inquiries from her majesty's
revenue and customs if you're
administratively minded this may be fine
for you but if you're already cutting it
tight to meet the deadline finding out
at 3pm on a friday that you've got an
intellectual property dispute to deal
with is an ugly situation number 10
always feeling like your work could have
been better
you probably want to start your business
because you're passionate and talented
at something but if there is one way to
turn a love into a labor it's to
monetize it you don't know what time
you're supposed to finish or
specifically how you're supposed to do
the job and you don't take any time off
from doing it but even if you get past
all that you are now the final quality
control check for your own work
and everyone else's the amount of time
that you will spend double and triple
checking work cannot be understated you
will wake up in the middle of the night
sweating because you realize that a
slide is missing from tomorrow's
presentation or you'll need to hotspot
off a tour guide's phone to update a
link on the website this
is the entry price you pay for being at
the top of the tree
the book will always stop with you so
the question you need to ask is
why are you thinking of working for
yourself presumably you want to be happy
and satisfied with your job but all of
the gains you make in increased freedom
and money and input each come with an
associated cost you will use up
willpower and spare time and sanity to
make this happen you need to work out if
that's truly a price that you're willing
to pay thank you very much for tuning in
press here to watch my video on what
happened when i stopped drinking for 1
000 days if you're wanting to start your
own business you'll need to be more
productive and taking a break from
alcohol is a really good place to begin
and don't forget to subscribe
peace